estamos aquí
manuel zapata tiene su propio huerto
donde ha sembrado algunas hierbas para
prepararse a diario infusiones que según
él le previenen del cobi 19
ante los altos costos de los
medicamentos que muchos no pueden pagar
algunos venezolanos han optado
reemplazarlos por recetas ancestrales
bien
[Música]
aunque médico y científico descarta en
el consumo de hierbas para protegerse de
el coronavirus el presidente nicolás
maduro fue el primero en recomendar la
medicina natural y sanador sabroso y
sanador el que lo quiera y el que no
esté de acuerdo que no lo haga para eso
y democracia y libertad
kausar gonzález tiene más de 10 años
vendiendo hierbas
cuando llegó la pandemia creó un combo
llamado el coronavirus que vende por 2
dólares y es una mezcla de varias
plantas entre ellas el famoso malojillo
también toronjil y hojas de guayaba esta
idea le ha traído grandes ganancias a su
negocio
ha sido la demanda cien veces más de lo
que se vendía
de ese pueblo lo más económico que viene
el convite todo de quitar malestar por
los químicos o pastilla mientras se
espera por la vacuna para el hobbit 19
los venezolanos sin dinero para pagar el
tratamiento seguirán tomando brebajes
que no tienen ningún fundamento
científico
este método de curación casero y el
deterioro del sistema de salud son una
mala combinación para quienes se
contagian en venezuela